en france une centaine de villes se
positionne sur le segment des congrès et
des conférences l'atout de tours la
proximité entre la gare tgv et le vinci
est un peu plus loin le parc des
expositions deux sites qui ont abrité en
2015 215 événement générant 90 mille
nuitées alors ses clients d'affaires en
fait ils viennent pour des réunions des
congrès des colloques des séminaires d
incentive
il ya beaucoup de possibilités ils
viennent aussi sur des durées variables
c'est à dire que par exemple la semaine
dernière on avait le congrès des
pompiers
donc là on avait une manifestation sur
plusieurs jours et là on a donc
accueilli des touristes d'affaires sur
plusieurs jours et vous allez avoir des
clientèle individuelle d'affaires ou là
ça va être plutôt une clientèle de
commerciaux qui sont de passage sur la
touraine des gens qui peuvent venir en
formation ou tippl venir passer un
concours sur la touraine et qui ont des
durées de séjour plus courte mais c'est
assez variable cette clientèle
individuelle de commerciaux est plus
importante que la clientèle de groupe
mais dans l'ensemble la clientèle
d'affaires est une réponse à la basse
saison lorsque les touristes sont moins
nombreux entre novembre et mars les
budgets alloués si vous du tourisme
d'affaires sont supérieurs à ceux
alloués à un tourisme de loisirs et il
faut savoir qu'un v6 dépense plus aussi
qu'un touriste de loisirs ce que je
voudrais avoir ici dans l'établissement
savoir 70 % de clientèle business et 30
% de clientèle loisirs parce que pour
moi la clientèle d'affaires elle est
présente toute l'année selon
l'association touraine hôtel un client
d'affaires dépenserait 150 euros par
jour
en restaurant taxis et autres services
contre une centaine d'euros pour un
touriste